and i respect mexico i respect their
leaders what they've done to us is
incredible their leaders are so much
smarter so much sharper
and it's incredible in fact that could
be a mexican plane up there they're
getting ready to attack
sometimes when you tweet you get
yourself in trouble you say cock-eyed
things
we don't know
we don't know whether you mean them or
whether you're just being a provocateur
sometimes both uh do your kids ever say
dad hey easy dad come on you're a little
here or there they love me and they want
to make sure that everything gets left
to them
[Laughter]
well yeah yeah
last time at the first debate we had
millions of people
fact fact-checking so i expect we'll
have millions more fact-checking uh
because you know it is uh
it's just awfully good that someone
with the temperament of donald trump is
not in charge of the law in our country
because you'd be in jail secretary
clinton
lisa or as i call her miss usda
i want you to be a judge
at my next miss universe patch because
like the universe
you're constantly expanding and filled
with dark matter
go take a look at the research says the
crime is the crime is that does not
match what you're saying the research
the pew research which is independent
says don't be naive you're a very naive
person the pew research says that there
are
for
immigrants on the whole create or come
on try getting it out try getting it out
i'll get it out i mean i don't know if
you're gonna put this on television but
you don't even know what you're talking
about nearly 200 dead
14 000 who are sick millions as you
witness who are scared right now what do
you say to americans who are watching
you right now who are scared
i say that you're a terrible reporter
that's what i say we'll do the wall
don't worry we're going to do the wall
we're going to do the wall and by the
way
who's going to pay for the wall
mexico's gonna pay for the wall i also
happen to call him a lightweight okay
and i have said that so i would like to
take that back he's really not that much
of a lightweight he hit my hands nobody
has ever hit my hands i've never heard
of this one look at those hands are they
small hands
and he referred to my hands if they're
small something else must be small i
guarantee you there's no problem i
guarantee go ahead sure
shocked that i picked her no it's like
in a state of shock
i'm not thinking that's okay i know
you're not thinking you never do i'm
sorry no go ahead
go ahead i said many times that the u.s
is doing far better than any other
country
when it comes to testing yes
why does that matter why is this a
global competition to you if every day
americans are still losing their lives
and we're still seeing more cases every
day well they're losing their lives
everywhere in the world
and maybe that's a question you should
ask china
don't ask me ask china that question
okay when you ask them that question you
may get a very unusual answer yes behind
you please and and who is the current uh
miss usa now well we have a miss usa
from
who the hell knows where she's from
she's from kentucky she went to new york
and she was hanging out at all the
parties doing what paris and lindsay do
you know dancing whatever and so he held
a press conference to announce whether
or not she was going to retain her crown
and then she started to cry so i used to
think donald just giving me a second
chance and really there he is
[Applause]
he's the moral authority left the first
wife had an affair left the second wife
had an affair had kids both time but
he's the moral compass for 20 year olds
in america donald sit and spin my
friends i don't enjoy him
well rosie o'donnell is disgusting i
mean both inside and out you take a look
at her she's a slob she talks like a
like a truck driver if i were running
the view i'd fire rosie i mean i'd look
her right in that fat ugly face of hers
i'd say rosie you're fired we're all a
little chubby but rosie's just worse
than most of us but it's not the
chubbiness rosie is a very unattractive
person both inside and out you've called
women you don't like fat pigs
dogs
slobs
and disgusting animals
your twitter account only rosie
o'donnell
it wasn't
your twitter account
you're the president and people tuning
in to these briefings they want to get
information and guidance and want to
know what to do they're not looking for
a rumor
i'm the president and you're a fake news
[Music]
sir why are you saying that to me
specifically i'm telling you i'm not
saying it specifically to anybody i'm
saying it to anybody that would ask a
nasty question that's not a nasty please
go ahead why does it matter okay uh
anybody else please go ahead in the back
please
no it's okay but you appointed to me i
have two questions mr next next place
you did you called on me i did and you
didn't respond and now i'm calling on
sorry young lady in the back please i
just wanted to let my colleagues okay
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
appreciate it thank you very much in
less than two years
my administration has accomplished more
than
almost any administration
in the history of our country
america's
so true
didn't expect that reaction but that's
okay
what's the difference between a wet
raccoon
and donald j trump's hair
a wet raccoon doesn't have
seven billion [ __ ] dollars in the
bank
hillary accidentally bumped into me
and she very civilly said
pardon me
[Applause]
reign in robert mueller
what a stupid question that is
what a stupid question but i watch you a
lot you ask a lot of stupid questions
okay
mr president
i know that you continue to say
okay hold on one second any other
questions from any other people
okay thank you very much everybody
now so you only miss universe and the
miss uh
you miss usa pageants miss america as
well well i might get them you know
we're on network television nbc your
favorite network just renewed it for
three more years oh and miss america's
doesn't have right now a network so i
don't know if that's a good thing or a
bad thing but now you've revitalized the
beauty pageants yeah i think i've done a
good job made them more interesting to
the home viewers and what was the key to
that what was the one thing that you
needed to fix well miss america made the
bathing suits one piece very large and
you weren't allowed to wear shoes what i
did is i made the heels higher and the
bathing suits smaller and it was amazing
it was amazing what happened to the
ratings
hunter you're a loser why did you get
1.5 billion dollars hunter
[Applause]
and your father was never considered
smart
he was never considered a good senator
he was only a good vice president
because he understood
how to kiss
barack obama's ass